hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
box night battle royale players
continually improve with every single
game the days of easy wins are numbered
and to be able to compete for victories
proves harder every day with that in
mind I wanted to bring you eight console
settings and secrets which I believe
will improve your game so if you're one
of those people who can only play on the
weekend this should help you stand
shoulder to shoulder with those that put
in 40 hours a week you ready let's do
this let's start with the most obvious
but also the most frightening to anyone
who has been playing from the start
the combat pro controller setting I'll
say it simply you must change to this
setup as quickly as you can
most of what I'm going to go through on
this video depends on that setting and I
don't want to waste your time anyway
with combat pro not only can your
weapons be switched to back and forth
but that's also the case for building
options other noticeable improvements
include using r3 to crouch which we all
know improves accuracy the old system
forced us to stop aiming to perform the
Crouch animation but was this way your
right thumb is always on the stick and
there's no excuse not to crouch before
firing I know it seems daunting to
switch control options especially if
you're hitting your mid twenties and
your ability to unlearn is quite a
struggle but stick with it I promise in
the long run you'll pick up more
victories I didn't win for 20 games
whilst learning combat pro and
considered switching back so many times
I feel your pain now that's out of the
way we can get to the real meat of this
video and a huge tip I want to offer how
often do you use the pyramid structure I
personally only use it to trap enemies
which isn't vital here's my suggestion
during the game lobby use the Edit
function to remove two of the furthest
squares away thus creating a ramp I know
it sounds ridiculous but let me explain
the input lag in game can be horrendous
the more button presses in a short
period of time increases this issue and
causes this stuttering effect in battle
we want to eliminate as much lag and
desynchronisation as possible and that's
why I use the pyramid
Niq let's put it into action let's build
a wall under ramp twice in standard
settings it takes 11 button prompts in
combat pro it takes well it still takes
11 button presses so that's not the best
way to showcase the combat pro option
but if we switch to the pyramid ramp
configuration we can knock off three
inputs from 11 button presses down to 8
what more in this quick scenario the
pyramid ramp build was 2 seconds faster
than the other options 2 seconds in
battle is a lifetime so I hope you
consider this option and if you're still
not convinced keep in mind the lag
issues less button presses usually mean
less chance of stutter lag which
infuriates us all in addition to this as
we aren't using the original ramp it can
be edited into something else for
example I like to rotate the ramp to a
down slope for safe descending from
roofs
I'm currently testing out the spiral
staircase option to allow me to build
vertically if stuck next to a mountain
simply puts by utilizing the pyramid you
can customize your build options
pre-fight to complement your play style
I really hope you consider it let's talk
about aiming on console and more
importantly aim-assist aim-assist is
most definitely needed on console as
your thumbs cannot gain the accuracy
compared to a keyboard and mouse if
you're playing on a pad don't turn it
off when aim assist works with you it
feels great and the random spread
element keeps us on our toes in the
search results headshots but the issues
arise when a misis works against you
have you ever been in a scenario where
you seem to be stuck behind the target
unable to hit them it's bloody stressful
isn't it well don't worry too much it
isn't a reflection of your ability it's
simply an aim assist issue we can't
solve but we can combat let's quickly
make sure we know what aim assist is as
your reticle crosses the target or
rather the vicinity of the target the
aim assist kicks in and helps stabilize
your shots towards the target in recent
updates this has been reduced massively
and thankfully the snipers no longer use
it but it doesn't do the job for you it
only assists the motions of your thumbs
if you begin to fire behind an opponent
the aim assist kicks in and actively
prevent you from
catching up to your target to stop this
we have two options the first is to move
your thumbs past the target but you will
need to exert additional pressure to
make it work
alternately you must stop firing
reacquire your targets and once again
start shooting essentially we all need
to lead our targets and allow them to
run into the bullets by doing this the
aim assist will live up to its name and
desist your accuracy we can go a step
further than this with our next point
it's time to talk about sensitivity
settings and right away I want to state
categorically that sensitivity is
completely subjective everyone is
different so don't let anyone make this
decision for you try on low medium and
high sensitivities until you find your
zone you'll need to play for hours for
your muscle-memory to adapt and those
tiny bits of fine-tuning that you will
need to make let's break down the pros
and cons so you can make an educated
decision low sensitivity is all about
bigger movements with your thumbs if
you're quite heavy-handed or if you play
in a freezing cold room this should be
your starting point when choosing
sensitivity when it comes to ranged
accuracy low sensitivity rules the roost
and by love sensitivity I mean between
one and three in your settings fights
from long and medium distances are
dominated by low sensitivity players so
if you prefer to use the assault rifle
burst rifle and to a lesser extent the
snipers think about trying controller
sensitivity 3 it's far easier to track a
target at range with a sensitivity
around 3 and there's a kicker to this to
the aim assist is hugely improved making
ranged encounters of breeze so put
bluntly low sensitivity will help the
aim assist high sensitivity on the other
hand will make range encounters a little
harder at first not impossible though
with practice a high sense player can
wipe the floor with anyone at distance
but as a starting point there is that
small issue of aim assist working
against you but we've already looked at
that the benefits for high sensitivity
around 6 and upwards allows for tiny
movements in your thumb sticks to be
recognized as official inputs this gives
players a huge range of motion compared
to
place Hisense is ideal for up close and
personal combats
so you double-pumped players you should
consider a higher setting to allow for
mobility when jumping around like a
headless chicken I was hoping to use my
own footage here but I hate double-pump
probably because I'm terrible at it high
sensitivity is great for verticality and
as we all know for tonight is all about
the high ground Anakin another little
advantage to high sensitivity is the
ability to look behind your character
without losing any speed watch any
professional player and you'll notice
the jump spin they constantly do to
check behind them on console this is
only possible with a sensitivity around
7 and above by using this you can run
into battle and check your flanks
without losing any momentum at all Oh
before I forget if your part is getting
a little old and worn out and you play
on a high sensitivity you may find
yourself doing this because of wear and
tear the thumbstick slightly pushes to
the side only a micro amount but if
you're on a high sensitive setting then
the game thinks that you want to run in
circles so you'll be stuck like this
you'll either need to buy a new pad or
lower the sensitivity to prolong the
life of your current pad on low
sensitivity the tiny offsets of your
thumbsticks would be completely ignored
by the console there's so much more
detail we could go into about controller
sensitivity but at this point I just
wanted to get the basics into all
console players at present I play in the
middle of both sensitivities after I
took a fortnight off bought night
there's a joke in there somewhere I came
back and found my settings were too high
and I reverted back to these starting at
6 I will play a handful of matches and
slowly change my sensitivity back up to
8 because I'm trying to get better with
shotguns I'm adapting my game due to the
horrific double-pumped meta which I do
hate but I need to stay competitive keep
in mind all this comes down to muscle
memory which can take many hours to
change so make a decision and slowly get
used to it but don't be afraid to adapt
to fine-tune to match your skillset and
always remember aiming down sights or AD
s and scope settings can be trained
independently of general sensitivity
that was far more in-depth than I
planned so let's go through a few
settings you may want to consider back
in the ps2 days aim and fire were always
on l1 and r1 rather than the triggers
underneath this was switched when the
trigger buttons were redesigned to feel
the same as gun triggers but they
actually take a fraction more time to
press and release than if you were using
l1 and r1 it's possible to switch these
buttons if you see fit on ps4 find
settings and accessibility and turn on
button assignments from here you can
reassign anything you desire while we're
here those of you who jump a great deal
in battle should consider switching the
assigned jump button to either a
shoulder button or a thumb trigger the
theory is simple to jump in the original
settings you must take your thumb away
from aiming for a split second unless
you hold the pad like a claw of course
switching the button here will result in
both your thumbs staying on the
thumbsticks and therefore more headshots
I've got to admit I wasn't going to
include that point as I hate double
pumper so much but it's for the greater
good I suppose whilst we're in the
settings let's improve our quality of
life with a few changes here if you are
ever searching a chest and your thumb
slips off the button and change the tap
to search function and now only a single
press is required in here I also make
sure I turn off vibration for a few
reasons
I find it impairs me for a split second
and also I like to preserve the battery
life and if you're on ps4 you will know
about the battery issues
I also recommend turning on the reset
building option which will always make a
wall the first option in your
construction arsenal if you are great at
remembering what the last thing you did
then switch this off but if you put down
random floors mid-battle yeah keep it on
to minimize issues
one more thing while we're here I also
recommend switching the option to stop
reloads when sprinting being stuck in a
load animation will lead to your death
from time to time but by using this
option you can safely run away before
you die pumping
into a shotgun this one is an old one
but the addition of the Black Knight I
think it needs revisiting brightness if
you have any trouble locating dark
characters under trees or in bushes and
crank this setting up I've had a great
deal of success sitting under the trees
when playing as the Black Knight not
many people tend to check trees but with
that skin on it's a real struggle to
spot so I'll stay ahead of the curve and
smash the brightness through the roof
only issue it looks awful detracts from
the game's beauty another stupidly
obvious one to end on but I think it
needs to be said again if you are
playing bar tonight put on a pair of
headphones to hear everything if you're
playing on your living room TV you'll be
surprised how many footsteps distant
sounds you were just completely missing
do yourself a favor and grab a headset
to even up the battlefield so there we
have it eight console settings and
secrets which I believe will improve
your game let me know what you think and
if the pyramid ramp technique is worth a
try
with 60fps coming to consoles soon time
saved using modded ramps will be
invaluable if I've missed anything let
me know and jump on our disco to chat
about fortnight and other video games
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade it's
been a bloody pleasure like always I'll
see you next time
[Music]